we're going to turn now to a major
development in the investigation of
former president Donald Trump's handling
of documents marked classified a federal
appeals court ruling one of his
attorneys will indeed have to testify
meanwhile the waiting game it continues
a possible indictment of trump from a
Manhattan grand jury regarding those
hush money payments to an adult film
star Robert Costa reports now from New
York
former president Donald Trump's lawyer
Evan Corcoran has been ordered by an
appeals court to testify about his
Communications with Trump concerning the
handling of classified materials
Corcoran could appear before the grand
jury as soon as Friday and must also
share any relevant evidence including
documents and private audiophiles I
think it's a really significant
development former Federal prosecutor
Harry Littman it could be absolutely
devastating evidence of Trump's guilt of
obstructing the investigation into the
return of the classified document it
could also be a prism into what Trump
said behind the scenes before and after
the FBI searched Mar-A-Lago last year
meanwhile a New York grand jury is
expected to meet again today as it
considers a possible criminal indictment
of trump related to hush money payments
made in 2016 to adult film star Stormy
Daniels according to sources the former
president huddling with advisors in
Florida has remain defy it and is
considering holding a news conference
outside the court in New York if he's
indicted a possibility that along with
protests has sparked security concerns
former New York City Police Commissioner
Bill Bratton nobody quite knows what to
expect in this historically uh
unprecedented event a possible
indictment of a former president
so New York fortunately has the
resources to operate always with an
abundance of caution
as the decision making on a trump
indictment carries on House Republicans
are ramping up their pressure on
Manhattan district attorney Alvin Bragg
with two former prosecutors from his
office now being called to testify and
share documents Vlad
all right Bob thank you very much